Michael qui roulait qui est le président
d'Alstom dans la région Amérique
monsieur qui roulait bonsoir bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous d'avoir accepté
notre invitation l'exigence pour ce
projet du tramway de Québec c'est un
minimum de 25% de contenu local donc de
contenu québécois est-ce que ce sera le
cas absolument comme nous l'avons
communiqué déjà depuis plusieurs
semaines puisqu'on est en discussion
avec la ville le train le tramway sera
conçu à notre siège social de Saint
Bruno et sera assemblée à l'apocatière
l'usine de La Pocatière l'usine très
importante pour nous dans laquelle nous
avons beaucoup investi pour recréer à la
fois des compétences de la charge de
travail et qui a donné lieu à une
reprise d'investissement importante donc
bien entendu c'est une usine importante
qui sera alimentée de manière très forte
par ce contrat soyez un petit peu plus
précis avec nous on dit minimum 25 on
dit combien quelle part au Québec et
qu'elle part au Mexique tout d'abord il
faut comprendre qu'un contrat comme
celui-là et un train complexe comme
celui-là n'est jamais fabriqué dans une
usine c'est toujours un ensemble
d'usines qui contribue à des
fabrications qui sont ensuite assemblées
la vision qu'on a aujourd'hui même si
c'est très tôt pour en parler puisque on
va rentrer dans deux ans de
développement avec la ville de Québec
qui va vous permettre de poser des
options c'est de positionner le scope la
plus forte valeur technologique à La
Pocatière et donc les ce qu'on appelle
les bougies c'est à dire ce qui peut
supporter les roues et l'assemblage
final qui est là où vraiment on a besoin
de de la plus grande expertise pour
pouvoir finir le train dans les respects
des règles et des normes plus fortes
expertise technologique du côté de
l'apocatière mais si je vous demande
quelle part au Québec quelle part au
Mexique qu'est-ce que vous me dites je
sais pas exactement d'où vient cette
cette information du Mexique on n'a
jamais communiqué sur le fait que le
Mexique allait fabriquer est-ce que ce
sera des informations on va rentrer là
dans deux ans de de
développement on une période de
développement qui va nous permettre de
encore une fois de considérer un certain
nombre de paramètres la charge de
travail des différentes usines de
l'apocatière en particulier
le marché dans lequel on est bien
entendu intégré c'est à dire où est-ce
qu'on va trouver les meilleurs pièces au
meilleur prix et c'est à l'issue de
cette période de deux ans qu'on va
pouvoir répondre à la question quel
pourcentage sera fait La Pocatière ce
qu'on sait aujourd'hui c'est que 25%
c'est un minimum on sera au dessus on le
sait déjà maintenant est-ce que ce sera
30 ou plus c'est une question à laquelle
on pourra ça pourrait être au complet à
La Pocatière non si jamais le cas ok si
jamais le cas et il faut comprendre que
d'abord c'est une nouvelle ligne de
produits pour l'usine de La Pocatière
une ligne de produits qu'on a amené à La
Pocatière spécifiquement en préparation
de ce contrat donc il y a une phase
d'apprentissage qui va aussi être
importante pour la fabrication ensuite
on a toujours des fabrications qui sont
partagées sur différentes usines c'est
le modèle d'une société comme la nôtre
et
de tous les les grands fabricants de
matériel roulants c'est d'utiliser un
réseau et d'utiliser la bonne
répartition en fonction des charges de
ces usines du réseau avec une majeur à
certains endroits le même par exemple
les fabriquer essentiellement en Inde
c'est vrai c'est vrai et donc le tramway
de Québec pourrait être fabriqué en Inde
pour être fabriqué au Mexique mais je
comprends qu'il ne pourrait pas
majoritairement être fabriqué au Québec
alors c'est encore une fois très
difficile de répondre à cette question à
ce moment à ce monde de d'avoir frustré
jouir parce que c'est un grand contrat
signé hier et donc
comment vous interprétez la réaction des
syndicats une série aujourd'hui qui ont
vraiment l'impression d'avoir des
miettes comme comme ils le disent à la
poche je pense que c'est d'abord très
tôt pour que les syndicats soient
inquiets on va rentrer dans une
discussion on continue à leur donner des
informations nos équipes sont en contact
avec eux on n'a pas eu de d'informations
magnifique sur le contenu de La
Pocatière donc c'est une information qui
aujourd'hui pas fondée sur sur un plan
industriel qui est figé donc il y a pas
beaucoup d'informations je vous écoute
là puis on en sait pas beaucoup les gens
sont dans l'expectative en quelque sorte
mais ce qui est important ce qui est
important c'est de revenir sur
l'histoire récente de l'apocatière quant
à l'estomac a racheté le bombardier
Transport l'usine était en panne de
commande du signe de La Pocatière
finissait la fabrication des rames azur
pour la STM et il n'avait plus de
commandes en suivant ça avec le support
du gouvernement et le prêt pardonnable
dont vous avez parlé au début on a
rapatrié de la charge de travail y
compris du Mexique vers l'usine de La
Pocatière aujourd'hui c'est 400
personnes on était descendu à 50
personnes dans l'usine
les engagements qu'on a appris pour 2026
sont remplacés sont respectés en 2023 on
a toujours eu un respect absolu de tous
les engagements qui avaient été pris
envers le gouvernement envers la caisse
et aujourd'hui on s'y tient absolument
et c'est sur cette base là qu'on va
développer le schéma industriel qui sera
le meilleur pour le tramway de Québec
pour l'apocatière pour nos employés donc
c'est pas encore le moment de rentrer
dans des discussions de ce niveau de
détail deux questions pour terminer
l'installation à l'administration Biden
va vite justement sur ses
investissements est-ce que des
investissements américains pourraient
bénéficier à La Pocatière en ce moment
on fabrique des pièces pour les trains
pour New Jersey transit à la pocketière
ça encore c'est des productions qui ont
été rapatriées d'autres usines vers
l'usine de La Pocatière donc aujourd'hui
l'usine de La Pocatière contribue à des
programmes aux États-Unis et ce sera le
cas dans le futur et ce sera le cas dans
le futur c'est notre modèle c'est à dire
que on utilise notre réseau y compris la
Pocatière pour produire des pièces qui
vont être ensuite assemblées dans
d'autres pays en l'occurrence aux
États-Unis pour le point new jazz et
est-ce que vous faites des
représentations d'activer en ce moment
pour que le TGF le très grande fréquence
entre Québec et Toronto deviennent un
TGV
alors vous avez probablement entendu
qu'on s'est positionné assez tôt dans la
faveur du TGV on a on pense que c'est la
meilleure option pour le Canada la
connexion entre Montréal est Toronto est
très achalandée en voiture en vol on
pense que c'est d'ailleurs c'est
confirmé par beaucoup de consultants
l'une des meilleures lignes haute
vitesse d'Amérique du Nord donc
aujourd'hui on pense que toutes les
conditions sont respectées pour que ce
projet soit un grand succès en train à
grande vitesse qui d'ailleurs n'enlève
rien à la fréquence puisque ça peut être
vitesse et fréquence et donc on pense
que c'est le bon choix le gouvernement
avec les investisseurs vont décider de
la direction à prendre dans les
prochaines prochains mois monsieur qui
roulait merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce soir merci d'avoir
beaucoup c'est un plaisir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]